well looks like it's turning into a
pleasant night at fenway
first one under the lights at fenway
park this season here's the red sox
starting pitcher presented by audi
last year 2-0 in a couple of starts for
the red sox at the end of the season
tsutsugo 197 last year has good power
3-2 hot shot matt sander boguts on the
other side
to make an outstanding play that was a
bullet
is austin meadows
hammered again to the right side
lurching ahead hernandez to get him
and margot will be next you talk about a
guy who was a pain in the neck
against the red sox last year two down
oh but he went he committed that is a
swing and a miss he got him and he's out
of the inning
he struck him out well making his first
start as a member of the tampa bay rays
is going to be right-hander michael
walka
hernandez the one guy in this lineup who
has seen him
a bit before
there's a cut and a miss and he takes
care of
hernandez alex verdugo left-hand batter
choking up on the bat close to the plate
and legs close together
gets his man there and boy that is a
nasty pitch
it really is two minute on with two but
out raphael debra is the third baseman
and he goes right back up again and gets
the chase out of the zone
so three strikeouts two men left we go
to the second
no score christian vasquez
three for seven on the season
base hit as vazquez stays hot he's now
hitting 500.
baskets advancing down to third on that
fly out
cordero up there from the left side and
they overshift on him
and two down and he'll fly that one high
and twisting to left
rosarina right there at the wall and
it's going to catch the 10.
and that's going to bring in a run down
to second
francie cordero yeah that ball was hit
well by quandaro
going to the opposite field he's so
strong looks like a fastball cut
fastball and he
takes it to the opposite field big guy
strong guy
he wouldn't even sure he hadn't played
at fenway very much
and he's now he's looking at this like
is that going to be enough to get off
the wall
gotta start running big guy if you don't
you're gonna be out at second base
rumor has that he was creeping in to be
part of the celebration not good the two
two swinging a line drive down the
left field line slicing toward the line
over and to his right is cordero really
nice range to make the play
red sox are really playing great defense
tonight that is encouraging and they're
two down
so with two down here is austin meadows
3-2 past him he struck him out
some emotion there from pavetta he gets
him in order
[Music]
and rodoga will slice that one it's
going to roll all the way to the base of
the wall
his first hit digging for extra bases he
is in there with a double
first fastball right over the plate and
badugo picks up his first hit of the
season
opposite field it's going to be a two
base hit
is one for one a single in the first
inning to left field
ground ball third out of second over to
first
they're gonna get both of them over to
third
goes verdugo and the rays turn the
double play
but hey this is where you can't let up
yeah you sometimes you get that big
double play and then all of a sudden
a guy like devers comes through you got
to stay locked in
on the ground and
well the double in the walk they do not
score we go to the fourth one nothing
boston
christian vasquez is one for one with a
bay city has scored the only run
hot shot a fair ball off that little
fence
and rockets back into left field and
holds him to one
here's marwin two-two hammered up the
middle and threw for a base hit
vasquez will put on the brakes at second
red sox in business again
red sox have a bunch of guys who are due
and here's one of them hunter renfro
he's over eight
he has flied to center oh for one
tonight
all the way to the backstop the runners
will advance vazquez to third gonzalez
into second
man 1-0 hammered the other way
long dive on what a play by rosarina
a spectacular play vasquez will tag it
he is in to score
i don't know if you're going to see a
better play by an outfielder
all season long that was spectacular
that was amazing i mean what an athletic
play that was by a rosarian i mean this
ball looked like it was going to go over
his head he
jumps dives catches it holds on to it
and gets it back in
man man that ball was headed for the
420. man
sensational unless you're hunter renfro
he does get an rbi out of it zander with
a single he's also hit into a five four
three double play walker delivers
swinger drive to right center feel it
well a rose arena going back still going
back this one is over his head it hits
off the bullpen wall he dives to stop it
into third jd being waved home here
comes the throw to the plate by adamus
it's off the glove of the first baseman
too late
throw the third goes down the left field
line and xander will score
the red sox get two and lead at five
nothing
top of the order and kiki hernandez
looking to make contact here it's been
tough
on him there tonight he struck out three
times two two coming
fly ball well struck center field ago
we'll see that off the bottom of the
wall red sox looking to add on
here's the throw home and gonzales
slides in
kk blasting away to dead center field to
make it six to nothing
with a double alex one for three with a
double runners at second and third only
one out
and got a pitch to handle a high fly to
left field
rosso coming on to make the catch
tagging up
and in to score is renfro to make it
seven to nothing
to lead off the eighth 2-1
is lined the other way that's going to
be high off the
green monster right back down to cordero
and that's going to be a long single one
out one on and that'll bring up randy
rosarino
on the ground up the middle and it takes
a big hop
by hernandez up to seconds at sugo
a couple base runners for the raise in
the eighth with one out
for brandon allow
[Music]
shot the other way into left for a base
hit
cordero makes the pick up rays have the
bases loaded and wellmark go
and that pitch is wide for ball four
and the rays will get on the board
yandy diaz is going to come off the
bench to hit in place of joey wendell
and way wide i mean these misses aren't
even close
so two men have been forced home via the
walk will bring up verdugo
alex has a double tonight and he has a
base hit tonight as well
trying to bring in another run renfro
will score as the throw comes into third
to make it eight to two alex verdugo in
his second rbi
jd martinez looking for his second knock
tonight
went after that one off the outside
corner down the line that one's sailing
and it is gone
into the pesky pole
a three-run homer for jd martinez
just guided that one down the right
field line into the pole
and the socks really blow it open in the
eighth inning